it's too difficult to evict tenants who
don't pay the rent we need more support
correct correct we're in a cost living
crisis a lot of landlords that can't
afford to have tenants that don't pay
them any rent and now not only are they
not making any money but they're
actually losing money because they're
still to pay the mortgage so morally
you're okay going to sleep at night yes
knowing that you have evicted a family
and put them out at risk of homelessness
onto the street you're okay with that
yes here's what irritates me right what
irritates me is when tenants tell me
they can't pay rent because their mom
just died they would never call their
energy provider and say I can't pay my
energy bill cuz my mom died they would
never call sabd and go in and say my mom
dad can have free food why did they come
to me they pray and leech and use
emotional manipulation on struggling
landlords with stories of why they can't
pay the rent and it's wrong so so you're
telling me that tenants are the ones who
are praying and leeching on corre
landlords correct I think there should
be empathy for people struggling I'll be
serve a very empathe empathetic eviction
mous what about people who like I said
can't afford food can't afford to feed
their families what does says we say
they say you can't come buy food unless
you have money you need money landlords
should be able to charge what they see
fit in terms of rent to protect their
property absolutely if you've got
something if you're selling a laptop who
chooses how much you sell that laptop or
you choose how much you sell the laptop
for if you overcharge and you say I know
it's only worth a grand but I want two
grand guess what's going to happen no
one's going to buy it it's the same with
properties if you've got a property and
the rent is worth a grand and you go
actually I'm going to put it on for two
guess what's going to happen you're
going to have an empty house that's
going to be two grand for this moldy
damp barely fit for purpose house that
the landlord thinks is fine to charge
that much money for landlords are able
to charge whatever they want for any
type of property it can be the most
amazing well-kept for property or it can
be literally a h we have a massive
shortage of house houses and every year
we fail to build the amount of houses
and as a result of that because there's
a shortage of houses there's way you
know I know I'll put a property on for
rent I have 27 applications I get it
housing is a right you have a right to
shelter you have a right to Safe shelter
if it's a right who's going to pay for
it if you're saying I should just have a
right to live in a house everything
should just be free who's going to pay I
didn't say it was for free I just said
it was a right okay well what do you
mean by a right you have to pay
that's called the world we live in that
pay should be in line with what you are
able to afford I have the right to be
able to live in my home and not fear
eviction right and I have the right not
to have my rent increase so drastically
every month or every year or whatever it
is MH to the point where I cannot afford
it so you're saying you have the right
to choose what you think is fair you
should just say I think it's fair to pay
this for a house therefore I have the
right to pay that I didn't say that I'm
I'm just trying to understand cuz it
don't make any sense I think homeless
shouldn't exist I think people should
not be homeless sure and people
shouldn't be sick either and isn't it a
shame that people die that's there there
not any that is not comparable in any
way absolutely not it's the world we
live in yeah of course people die that's
just life but homelessness is not life
homelessness is a societal problem
homelessness is something that we've
created but you have no Solutions of how
to fix it you just say I'd like it if it
was just given to me at the price that I
want to pay do you have the answers to
everything in the world no but I have
the to this it's called a free market
the amount of properties landlords own
should be capped agree 100% I'm building
right now a block of 48 houses should I
be allowed to do that you should be
allowed to build them but you shouldn't
be allowed to profit from
them how many properties do you have
hundreds hundreds yes right so you are
probably making a significant income
from all of those properties if I wasn't
making money from building properties I
wouldn't do it and if no one does it
guess what there's going to be way less
Supply and rents are going to be 10
times the price and you're going to be
moaning about it even more you shouldn't
profit of them as a landlord so you're
saying I should be forced to sell them
all but I can make a profit in selling
job this is way more important than most
jobs this is the very thing that you
have a problem with which is the lack of
supply of properties I'm there building
these properties and you're saying go
get a job what the should be funded by
the government the supply of property
should be funded by the government not
by people who have to pay more money to
you and put it in your personal pocket
my landlord right owns my whole building
there's four flats in it including my
own from my building alone he earns
£60,000 a year double is that it that's
double what the average UK salary is
good for him he deserves that
significantly more than what I earn and
then I put 60% of my income straight
into his pocket good and I will never
buy a house because that money I will
never see that money I'm giving money to
someone right for a place that I don't
own that I can't make changes to that I
can't paint I can't you know decorate I
can't put things on the wall without
permission I can't have a pets without
permission but the thing is everything
you're saying balls down to I want the
government to help me the government
should solve the problems they don't
that's not the real world you live in
the property you should fix it or take
better care of it depends on what it is
I've literally had people call me up and
say my lights aren't working it's an
emergency and then I've been like oh man
they're not working I'm so sorry bang
send someone out paid an emergency
electrician and light bulbs just need
change it yeah I personally do agree
that you should change your own light
bulb but also what then happens like so
some people have made repairs or like
fixed up their property or like whatever
you know changed their property in some
way you know and change the light bulbs
but their landlords are like you
shouldn't have done that cuz like we're
supposed to be in they're just idiot
idiot landlords I've had a landlord like
that they were like oh you have to call
us every time like when you need the
light bulb Chang so I can buy my own
light bulb I want I want to put a
picture up on the wall you're not
allowed I'm I'm not about that life my
tenants are my customers they give me
money they should be grateful to me I
should be grateful to them win-win so
what happens in that situation a
landlord doesn't fix something after
multiple complaints you know and it's
something really dangerous like mold or
damp something that will hurt you which
costs billions to the you talk about
landlords not fixing things mold
problems that's that's a real issue
imagine if the government C rents now
now I'm not fixing now now I'm not
making any profit how am I supposed to
fix stuff land Lords let tenants live in
dangerous or hazardous conditions yeah
they do and it's wrong I can agree with
that yeah yeah there are some really bad
landlords I tell you who's worst who's
the the worst landlord is there the
council look at um gemfield Tower yeah
and all the disgusting horrible things
that that have happened the council
houses are the worst so when people say
we should just rely on the government to
provide all that housing it's like whoa
mm come to me man come to me I'll give
you better houses believe me and you'll
pay me and it's cool but build houses
don't go to the government government
terrible I'm a landlord not a bad guy
why do we have such a bad rep I think
landlords have such a bad reputation
because renters are extremely frustrated
where they can be evicted at a moment's
notice you know where their rents can
increase at a moment's notice forcing
them out of their area forcing them to
find new housing at the drop of a hat I
think it's all these horror stories that
we've heard they're frustrated that
they're pouring thousands of pounds into
this home that they you know reap no
reward from you know they're just
putting that money into their landlord's
pocket and you know if if they're paying
£30,000 of rent a year that that money
if they had saved all of that up they
would have a house you know they could
be able to buy a house true I don't
think that greedy landlords truly exist
generally speaking because the way you
see it is oh if you're greedy and money
grabbing and don't fix things you make
more money that's actually not the case
from my experience of the thousands of
investors that I have met and talked to
and seen their books the ones that treat
their business like a true business and
care about their customers see their
house as a product and a service and
their tenant as a customer and look
after them they actually make more money
the greedy slum landlords are often
broke so they should be so I I think
there's this skewed narrative that these
greedy landlords that are making all
this money they're not they're idiots
have you ever seen those horror stories
about people who like you know they
change the shower heads like till a
nicer one or you know painted and it was
like nicer and then they you know got
their deposit taken away or their
landlord just I think it's disgusting I
hate it interesting okay yeah
cool do you think this has been hashed
out I think it's been hashed out really
well I think I think neither of us will
come to an agreement on like certain
things but I think on some things we do
have common ground and we do agree
ostensibly on like a lot of things so
yeah I think it's been hashed out pretty
well yeah I think so I think you're a
very articulate person I think you
deserve to be very successful in
whatever you do I've been a tenant so I
get it um but I think you need to begin
to be a bit more grateful to me for the
houses that I'm building that' be good
sure maybe on a call day in hell to
you I think that was really interesting
I think that there's nothing more
healthy than debating with people that
you disagree with it was it was lot of
fun really enjoyed it it was really
interesting to kind of hear his
perspective you know it was nice that we
were able to kind of have like a
conversation and do and we did come to
agreement on certain points even if
overall maybe we disagree with each
other I wouldn't say it's changed my
perspective at all hopefully it changed
her perspective just a little bit Yeah I
think my perspective has changed a
little bit on a few things I think maybe
I probably should read up a little bit
more on like the kind of Economics of it
and of like rent controls I'm from a
workingclass background I know what it's
like to be a tenant I'm very aware of
the problems it's just the solutions
that she was giving me just didn't make
any logical sense at all and have tried
and have been tried and tested and
failed measurably I think I would sit
down with him for another chat I think
we both had a lot of interesting things
to say but clearly there are some things
I need to learn more about some things
he needs to learn more about so maybe
once we've both read up a little bit
more on both of on those things then we
could you know sit down again and talk
about it and have a more well-rounded
perspective overall I would definitely
sit down for another chat with her and I
think we could I have a feeling we're
going to end up being friends one day
hopefully I can help her get into
property and become a millionaire then
she'll change her mind real quick